[Music]
unless you're in my body
you don't know Aaron Carter in tears
[Music]
opening up exclusively to et about his
battle with body image issues that have
a hiatal hernia I have a stress
condition as an eating disorder how
would you feel every ever every two
seconds seeing a tweet view of aids go
die oh look at this method Oh meth kills
crack kills with the mighty right
yeah look at my teeth look at my face
I'm not a method I've never touched it
anyway it's body shaming it is the
toughest thing to deal with when you're
looking in the mirror and you see
yourself is it hard to see they're not
cheap change oh my god it hurts so bad
air it's air it's so bad because there's
like nothing I can do about it there's
so many people out there that don't
think those celebrities are in Cirque
yours are you insecure I get voluma
dollars okay to fill up my face because
you've lost so much weight that it's
sunk in no it's just how I'm built this
is how I look is there anything else
that you do yes I get voluma I get
Juvederm and then Restylane so do you
believe that stress through music
through chocolate Irfan no no I do it
with my fans on when I do
periscopes and they're you know they're
all really positive
[Music]